klein ja ok aber ist es nicht so schlimm
ist nicht so schlimm
nein doch es ist schwierig
also leute seid wirklich gespannt aufs
endergebnis das kann ich euch das licht
ans herz etwas gedacht und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich meine haare sitzen
gut ne oder hast du bist heute kann man
mit arbeiten
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut heute
ich freue mich so darauf man muss sagen
man muss hier ganz klar maria veen weil
er auf die idee gekommen ist oder das
ganze gesehen hat und zwar haben wir uns
gestern abend oder vorgestern haben mir
viele videos reingezogen wieso leute
solche technik angewendet haben
die nennt sich the pinup modeling genau
und zwar haben wir schon gesehen
computer-handys das ist also eine
technik damit kann man gegenstände
verfärben und jetzt wahrscheinlich am
titel auch schon gelesen wir versuchen
heute mal wirklich richtig neiße goldene
airports zu kreieren die dann am ende
auf wie immer jetzt den moment instagram
account daher ist ja nie verlost werden
ihr müsst einfach immer dann auch die
story antworten und irgendwie kriegt die
dann hier haben wir die airports also
das sind airports ihr seht schon wir
haben eingekauft und ich glaube es ist
wichtig dass ihr euch vorher mal so ein
zwei sachen zu dieser technik erkläre
ich bin jetzt auch noch keinen profit
aber ich gebe einfach mein bestes wir
werden deshalb erst mit den airports
versuchen und dann später auch noch mit
anderen gegen ihr könnt gerne mal ideen
dafür in die kommentare schreiben
auf jeden fall geht es darum diese box
kommt vielleicht wasser in wein werden
diese verschiedenen sprayfarbe
hinzugegeben und in diesem wasser ergibt
sich dann ein muster und wir machen das
heute mit gold und weiß das heißt wir
haben später so gold weiß erfurts
allerdings soll gold auf jeden fall
überwiegen dann werden diese airports da
rein getunkt einmal das case und einmal
auf die einzelnen potts oder wie man so
auch immer nennt in ear kopfhörer sagen
wieso
und dann schauen wir mal wie das am ende
aussieht und ich bin richtig gespannt
denn ich glaube es könnte cool aussehen
hoffen wir es mal so ich würde sagen ich
war erstmal ein bisschen wasser rein und
dann kommt wird somit kann man hier
vielleicht haben wir gestern mal so ein
bisschen geübt
wir haben das schon mal gemacht
allerdings ist das jetzt eher weniger
heiß geworden wobei wer hat schon so ein
glasreiniger meistens reicht bis obenhin
okay bei 8000 noch mal dass meine ganzen
playstation oder und dann irgendwann mit
iphone 11 so alles klar
wichtig ist jetzt erst mal ich mach mir
dafür aus genauso ich hier drin spray
das stinkt halten auf jeden fall was wir
jetzt erstmal machen müssen ist das case
und auch die airports abzukleben das
heißt es sei kein wasser eindringen kann
das mache ich mal eben muss man das was
man erst das case machen sind
[Musik]
also leute wir haben das jetzt gerade
hier alles abgeklebt sofern man das
sehen kann
damit hält gleich kein wasser rein kommt
wenn wir die ins wasser tunken und was
man noch dazu sagen muss wir haben auch
hier die kopfhörer abgeklebt das war
echt ziemlich in millimeterarbeit ich
bin auch mal gespannt ob das wirklich
cool aussieht weil wir sind die erste
gas machen ich habe noch kein einziges
video gesehen wo dass jemand versucht
hat deswegen dürfen meist klappt sagen
wir so wir versuchen es das case wird
auf jeden fall klappen und dann haben
wir goldene r putzt letzte was wir jetzt
als erstes machen ist ganz ganz wichtig
wir gehen auf dem balkon und sprechen
dass hier mit weißer lackfarbe an jedes
werk habe damit eine matte oberfläche
entsteht damit die andere farbe haften
kann
und das machen wir jetzt mal was am
besten direkt im 1
so leute also bitte
wenn es noch nicht trocken
ok jetzt kommt es drauf an
ich liege das wahrscheinlich gar nicht
so mit aber es ist ein verdammt
aufwendiges was wir schon alles gemacht
haben
deswegen jetzt kommt es darauf an wie
schon gesagt wir wollen wir jetzt
erstmal ordentlich goldrain weil wir
wollen ja dann gold airports haben das
war schon ganz neues und ich würde sagen
3 2 1 deckung und das ist günstiger aber
ist im wasser wie gesagt das ist unser
erster versuch deswegen nimmt sich
wieder gott ja was sie schon können
[Musik]
also leute werden jetzt hier das muster
und wir checken jetzt mal ob's klappt
ganz langsam rein damit die farbe auch
gut an essen kann man sehr schnell 5 1
und bereitet
jetzt lass es jetzt kann es unsinn kann
man ja sehen dreht das mal okay naja ich
mal gespannt aber er sieht schon ganz
cooler ist eigentlich nichts halt mehr
weiß als gold wir können ja gucken wir
das gleich mit klarlack osten jetzt
müssen wir noch bis hin dass ab 10
und kommt mir meine hand also wenn das
halt dann klar ist und man es vielleicht
noch so ein bisschen ab schreibt könnte
es noch ganz gut aussehen oder warum das
du dicker kommen auch meine finger
lassen die ganze ich glaube ja gar
nichts abbekommen hatte
wir haben mehr weiß als gold haben
nochmal rein tun ja jetzt raus
ja ok aber ist es nicht so schlimm ist
nicht so schlimm
doch nein doch es ist richtig das sind
hier nudeln machen
das macht man auch goldene nudeln ich
würde deshalb nur weil das jetzt so ein
bisschen komisch aussieht das heißt noch
gar nichts gelaufen also leute seid
wirklich gespannt aufs endergebnis das
kann ich euch das will ich euch ans herz
und erhält viel reales hält er ist nun
klar willst es bei den muss also lassen
wir wohl nur sowas so nun ist das
trocknen der kinostar für so was schon
mal ganz gut wir führen jetzt so ein
bisschen weil die sind auch ziemlich
nass und auf die farbe ist noch nicht
ganz trocken dann polieren wir die ganz
leicht und dann kommen noch klarlack
drüber und dann hoffen wir dass es geil
aussieht aber an sich so ich bin
halbwegs zufrieden
die nächste folge drehen wir auf jeden
fall draußen weil das auch nicht so
gesund
nee das war absolut falsch ja also wir
sind ein schlechtes vorbild trotzdem
kommt jetzt hier noch klarlack drauf
dann werden die dinger wieder befreit
von diesen gummiteilen damit halt kein
wasser rein läuft bis rallye ja muss
reichen mann ins trommelt das noch
kurzfilm stunde später
leute wir haben das ganze jetzt noch
draußen trocken lassen weil es halt
einfach irgendwie nicht trocken wurde
mit dem film jetzt ist allerdings
trocken und jetzt können wir das ganze
vor diesen gummiteilen befreien gehört
darum gemacht haben habe ich am anfang
schon ganz viel zu erklärt ich würde
sagen wir starten mit dem case hat kann
man hier so schon automatisch ab und du
hast ja gesagt man muss es richtig
gründlich machen aber eigentlich geht es
noch ganz gut aus oder oh ja also
natürlich jetzt nicht perfekt aber ich
finde es jetzt nicht schlimm also es
fällt ja nicht auf ok und dann kommen
jetzt hier die dinge hat wenn man hier
ein sack was man halt sagen muss meine
finger sind komplett geschickt also ja
ihr könnt ja sehen und das hier ist das
letzte hinten um käse und da man sich
jetzt auch weißen was sagst du also hat
er schon gesagt ist unser erster versuch
deswegen es geht auf jeden fall besser
also wer hat uns gleich noch besser
hinbekommen können ich bin allerdings
zufrieden
also es ist sieht das nicht mega staus
ist halt ein cooler farbverlauf solberg
wird er solche r platz und jetzt kommen
bald hier noch zu den kopfhörern dass
wir das glaube ich die schlimmste arbeit
aber es geht eigentlich okay meine hände
kleben jetzt brutal
es war echt mega arbeit wie lange haben
wir dafür jetzt gebraucht also schon ein
paar stündchen ich glaube es liegt aber
auch daran weil das so viele finger
arbeit war bei der playstation die wir
dann vielleicht vorhaben wir 8000 likes
oder einem iphone eventuell irgendwann
macht lassen nach oben da dann machen
wir das und hier kommen jetzt die beauty
schutz vor den airports einmal
vielleicht vorher und danach her und ich
bin auf jeden fall zufrieden wie gesagt
schon bei unserem vorbei da sind jetzt
welchem einer story könnte darauf
antworten und irgendwer wird dann konnte
wird dass er gewonnen hat und im
schicken sie dazu ich hoffe ihr freut
sich oder sich freut sich und jetzt ab
mit irdischer plätze
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das war's mit dem video abonnieren licon
morgen 19 uhr sehen wir uns wieder ins
koma lag speed autolog aktivieren
[Musik]